foreign
students Run for Cover in heart too
like millions of others they've been
trapped in the city for more than two
weeks
the United Nations is warning Sudan is
falling apart as the Army and the
paramilitary group the rapid support
forces battle for control there are
shortages of food water fuel and
Medicine
honest to God we work in difficult
conditions we open the pharmacy despite
the sound of gunfire for the sake of
families and children our problem is how
to get stock the factories in the
battery region were bombed
the interior Ministry has deployed extra
police officers in cartoon stop looting
but what people really want is a
permanent ceasefire so far several
foreign mediated truces have barely held
These Are Soldiers near a bridge that
connects hartum North to the city of
omdaman both are under heavy bombardment
as is the area around the presidential
Palace and Army Headquarters the rapid
support forces says it's destroyed a
convoy of 200 army vehicles near there
in recent days
every day thousands of people decide
it's no longer safe to stay this rescue
ship in Port Sudan is taking evacuees to
Saudi Arabia
around 5 000 syrians say they're being
processed more slowly than other
nationalities
we've been here for eight days the
evacuation of syrians has stopped the
day before yesterday only 27 people were
evacuated no syrians were evacuated
yesterday we do not know what is
happening and no one gives us a clear
answer in our gene on the Egypt Sudan
border satellite images show queues of
buses waiting to take people across
others have flown home on the first two
days of the war it was action in Port
sedan with a couple of jets flying over
and some bombs Landing but in ports then
itself it was quiet so a lot but
obviously a lot of military action but
no fighting
everyone's teens everyone but but even
the Sudanese people we work with wanted
to go back to normal because they just
want their country to to grow and
prosper
former prime minister Abdullah hamdork
has added his voice to those calling for
an end to the conflict
warning could deteriorate into one of
the worst civil wars in the world
Victoria gatenby Al Jazeera
on our correspondent hibber Morgan joins
us now live from the Sudanese Capital
Khartoum here but there's only a few
hours to go before the supposed
ceasefire ends but there have already
been airstrikes has that actually made
any difference
well right now on the ground both sides
are claiming that they have the upper
hand while civilians say they've been
caught up in the middle in the city of
umdurman for example in the early hours
of Sunday there was Heavy Artillery
strikes and airstrikes launched by both
the Sudanese Army and the rapid support
forces on each other's positions so
people there say that or at least in
parts of onderman say that they cannot
see the ceasefire Holding On The Ground
then there's the northern part of the
capital Bahrain right now there are
plumes of smoke covering parts of the
city of bahri residents say that they
have been hearing some some shootings
and some gunfire being exchanged between
the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army but in other parts of the
capital they say that it's been
relatively quiet giving them the chance
to be able to go out and buy food or
other basic Commodities that's in the
Southern and Eastern Parts but people
are saying that this is the issue of
cash and they say that as long as the
fighting continues as long as the two
sides continue to try to battle each
other out to resolve their differences
they will be suffering of course and
here but as the fighting continues are
you hearing any word there of how
mediation efforts are perhaps going
mediation efforts have not stopped since
the start of the fighting on 15th of
April but the two sides seems to have
conditions on in regards to coming to a
negotiating table and working out a deal
or a ceasefire agreement now the
Sudanese Army General General Abdel
fattah al-burhan spoke to a U.S public
broadcaster on Friday and he says that
to negotiate with the rapid support
forces it has to include them being out
of the military institution then you
have the rapid support forces saying
that they will not negotiate unless
there's a ceasefire in place and all
previous ceasefires has ended with
accusations from both sides of violating
it the Sudanese Army is saying that the
rsf is trying to bring in more
reinforcement to continue the battles in
hortum and that they were able to shoot
down or or launch airstrikes on several
of the rsf convoys while the rsf is
saying that it managed to imprison
several uh Army several army officers
and soldiers in the city of ondurman so
it looks like while all International
Community bodies and Regional bodies are
trying to get the two sides to mediate
or to reach some kind of deal to
embassies fire for humanitarian Aid to
come in both sides want to make sure
that they have the upper hand before
they go to any negotiations to work out
what's happening in Sudan of course here
but Morgan there with all the latest for
us from Khartoum thank you Heba well
let's bring in Khalid Hassan he's the
acting Sudanese ambassador to the UK he
joins us now from London Khalid we're
into the third week of fighting now how
functional is the government at the
moment in cartoon are you getting
regular updates
yeah of course I'm getting regular
updates and the government is working
also it's not in its full capacity
because of this Rebellion but it's
working so when you say working so
government departments are functioning
are there big holes in terms of being
able to run a country
you know some of the civil servants just
travel outside the cartoon to celebrate
it holidays and they grow up there
because this Rebellion uh started and
they couldn't come back to their normal
life and normal words but the government
some of the government's body are
working although the services or the
people is very difficult
but they work very hard to provide it
like work you know what I do services
sure sorry the line's not great I I just
wanted to pick up on something you said
there you referred to this as being a
rebellion I want to talk about mediation
now correspondent hibber was just
touching on that you yourself I believe
have praised Saudi efforts on brokering
this later ceasefire which hasn't
exactly held but I believe you've also
been a little more dubious about Western
involvement
yeah actually we we transport our
brotherly and friendly countries who uh
call usan who who offer to mediate in
this uh situation in Sudan uh we have uh
we got the
initiatives that's a leading by by Sir
Baker the president of South Sudan and
Djibouti and
Indian president that's the one now I
think on the table absolutely and U.S
initiative mainly about ceasefire and
humanitarian tools
well I want to also look at how we got
here because I think that's crucial as
to how it potentially ends you are
currently acting ambassador to a country
that was one of a quad of countries
leading talks around the framework
agreement and that and a transition to
civilian Rule now feel very very far
away but you think that the way that was
handled is what caused this
yeah I went off of the main causes of
this uh conflict is is that the
framework agreement because it's
isolated uh a very important uh
political videos and also the
integration of the uh private support
forces into the army those I think two
points
uh where the mainly points that uh
created the problem now and so you think
Western Powers have essentially created
the climate for this to take place
I can't say that but uh
the the
extreme work agreement lead to this
sure I know that you and your government
have said that right now you're fighting
to protect civilians but there have
already been huge deaths huge
displacement the humanitarian situations
obviously rapidly deteriorating not only
in Khartoum now across borders too in
your mind how does this end
the other part of the country life is
normal but uh after it's very very
difficult for people to go get you know
food medicine clean water electricity
but the government is trying to do
best to end this rebellion and to retain
life uh
back to normal as soon as possible and
we have seen yesterday that the police
is on the ground and able to start uh
trying to get me the their needs from
the near shots so
gradually life is getting back to the
snow so you say you're doing everything
you can to help end the conflict I want
to ask you though as a member of General
burhan's government what is your message
then to the rapid support forces
[Music]
their salaries from Sudan government and
uh
they should put down their arms and join
the dinosaur forces and they will get
amnesty as uh either of Army and the
president said before
Khalid Hassan the acting Sudanese
ambassador to the UK speaking to us from
London thank you for your time sir thank
you for joining us here on altazira
foreign
is one of the country's leading peace
negotiations and its foreign affairs
minister says fighting isn't the
solution
All The Observers are telling us that
actually they want to
finish the war on the military ground
one should should Prevail that's the
message we receive but we cannot ask the
region except that that happened because
uh we we don't know when this uh victory
of one party on the other will happen
and until then the population in
Khartoum the people of Sudan you know
are you suffering
meanwhile the wild food program is
warning that the fighting in Sudan could
plunge the entire East Africa region
into a humanitarian crisis it says a
third of Sudan's population was starving
even before the fighting broke out now
there are shortages of food and prices
are soaring there have been similar
price Rises too in neighboring South
Sudan and Chad which have taken in
thousands of refugees well our
correspondent ahmedidris is in the
Border Town of adre in Chad with more
people are still coming uh one of the
first camps set up by the international
organizations like the United Nations I
had more than 4 000 refugees who have
been registered formally with hundreds
more uh still looking in trying to
register themselves and their families
in that particular camp and yesterday we
moved to a different Camp which is
majigilda there we found between 400 4
500 to 5 000 refugees in that particular
camp and we also understand not far from
where we are right now some people have
uh sort of moved their families
especially women and children and are
located in a village just close by here
although there is no presence of eight
organizations in that place so we expect
hundreds more uh located in that
community and they are spread within
families and also spread under trees and
in the Open Spaces basically the United
Nations and other agencies who are
trying to help these refugees are
projecting to help at least 20 000
refugees in the past one week or so but
what we're seeing right now the refugee
numbers could go much much higher than
that already the amount of food being
delivered is not sufficient enough to
last a family for five days so what
we're looking at probably unless food
Aid arrived you will have significant
issues here health issues malnutrition
issues already the United Nations
Children's Fund is talking about dire
situation for children
what a large number of people from South
Sudan are also trying to return home
Harry mutasa is in the capital there
Juba
the International Organization for
migration says there are about 1.5
million people from South Sudan living
in Sudan some of them are refugees
others when they're looking for work
when the fighting started people like
anak Ding and her six children left
Khartoum and came here to South Sudan's
capital Juba a journey that took them
about two days by bus and they're now
staying with family friends who've taken
them in for as long as it takes and
knockding says the journey for her and
the children to get here was traumatic
my children heard gunfire and saw things
they should never see they are still
scared I am happy we got back to South
Sudan savely
foreign
ERS close ties with its neighbor Sudan
remember this country gained
independence from Sudan in 2011. many
people still have friends and family
stuck in Sudan and they're worried about
what's happening over there
same experience that Sudan went is what
I went through in our crisis in South
Sudan where we have witnessed people of
being killed people have lost lives
people have been displaced and children
and and elderly people have suffered
most so when I saw the fighting in Sudan
it worries me more because I start
wondering the pain that the Sudanese
people are going through salvacare
saltadan's president is leading
mediation efforts as part of the
regional group egad he's trying to get
officials from the Sudanese Army and the
paramilitary RSA face-to-face talks here
in the capital of Juba government
officials say it's still a work in
progress
well many people who had submitted their
travel documents to foreign embassies
are still stranded in Sudan that's after
Western diplomats fled the country
rahila Mohammed has been taking a look
at that for us
some Sudanese say they are trapped in
Khartoum without their passports tens of
thousands of people are fleeing to
neighboring countries dozens of foreign
governments have flown out their
citizens and diplomatic staff but for
some Sudanese leaving is not an option
as their travel documents are locked in
shuttered embassies
while we spoke to Sudanese residents
still stuck in the capital after failing
to retrieve their passports
by the end of March I have applied for a
study visa to South Africa and by the
day of 18th of April after three days
before starting most of diplomats and
different Embassy staff were evacuated
so I couldn't reach my passport so I
can't go anywhere
I didn't get any response from the
embassy no announcement no phone calls
even no direct messages I applied for
the Schengen visa at the Swedish Embassy
in Horton
I didn't get my passport back because
the the staff simply up and left with
complete disregards to the situation uh
it's not just me there are hundreds of
us in different EU embassies it's
utterly irresponsible and and it's such
a shame because they are they spend a
lot of money on on Curbing the
migrations illegal migration when they
can't even come up with an Evita system
so situations like this do not happen I
emailed the Spanish Embassy multiple
times and I called them multiple times
but when they found out I was in Spanish
they hang up without an explanation me
and my family forced to leave our house
in her Thomas it was no longer as if my
family scattered me and my brother came
to Port Sudan but he got on the ferry to
Jeddah my mother and sister are
currently in the Egyptian border trying
to cross to Egypt and I'm here not
knowing what I will be doing next
imagine a lot of people are trying to
figure out what happening with their
papers by contacting governments on
Twitter the Dutch foreign Ministry
recently replied to a Visa query
confirming that a number of Sudanese
passports had been left behind at the
embassy it advises people to apply for a
new passport with local authorities
another criticism of foreign governments
is automated responses dozens of people
are sharing their frustrations online as
well now some countries are trying to
work around those changes on the ground
the Swiss Embassy says it's working hard
to find options for people to collect
their passports and the Chinese Embassy
says Sudanese residents can now collect
their documents in Khartoum now with so
many people in limbo you may be
wondering what are the legal
implications Sudan has signed a number
of treaties including the international
Covenant on civil and political rights
it states everyone lawfully within the
territory of a state shall within that
territory have the right to Liberty of
movement and everyone shall be free to
leave any country including his own
rights groups say governments can be
held liable for not doing enough to
return passports to Visa applicants